you know that we always hear advice for
people you work hard in this business
put in more than 40 hours a week to get
ahead always be involved in some project
whether it's paying or not what are some
of the surprising things you've learned
about this business that people wouldn't
expect regarding success that maybe your
father or grandfather imparted to you um
my father and my grandfather were the
consummate New Yorkers you know my
grandfather went to nightclubs six
nights a week Broadway shows he was
getting anecdotes for for his column in
The New York Post every day he was as
New York as it gets and travel was
something that was coming into vogue
obviously as he was making a name for
himself and he was fortunate enough to
be able to travel to some places on a
lot of inaugural flights and but he
didn't travel a lot and then my dad is
this this you know midtown Manhattan guy
loves New York City and and and works
you know worked really hard but kept it
rather local I've learned from this
business and it was surprising to me
when I moved out here to LA just how
much people travel in all hasit I all
facets of the movie business from
producers to actors to you know
directors and the people from the studio
publicize the movies I mean people are
on the road an insane amount and then it
really speaks to the world marketplace
and how movies have now you know the
fact I said now more than ever really
are shared around the world and I think
that that's something that I learned
firsthand here is being able to travel
to London to visit a set of Harry Potter
or to cover our junket in Egypt or to go
to you know a film festival in Australia
I mean you just you see how movies now
our soul beloved and shared around
the world especially American films and
I feel like that was something I was
surprising to me I thought I moved to LA
and I'd set up shop here in Hollywood
and I'd kind of stay put here but I'm
rarely in Los Angeles for more than 10
to 12 and 12 days at a time I feel like
I was I'm always on the road somewhere
and that was really surprising to me
when I when I got this this kind of job
you